here is Democrat Governor of Maryland
Wes Moore he's very upset that in
Florida and other places we're not
letting kids chop their genitals off and
learn about how to have anal sex weird
why do you think this has become a
passion project of some conservatives I
continue hearing people making the
argument that we're doing it because we
want to prevent our students from having
discomfort or guilt because we don't
want our students to be able to really
wrestle with these really difficult
things in times when they're maturing as
individuals and difficult historical
points
but the thing I realized and I wanted to
speak out about it is that's actually
not true
it's it's a guys it's not about making
kids uncomfortable it's not about making
kids feel uncomfortable
it's about
telling other kids
that they shouldn't understand their own
power
it's castoring them what
you are the one who wants to castrate
children number one
number two you freaks you weirdos it has
nothing to do with making kids
uncomfortable and guilty it has
everything to do with what is the role
of the state in a child's life and the
role of the state in a child's life in a
sane Society a society that we had for
roughly 250 years had nothing to do with
a third grade teacher talking to a child
privately about their genitals for
months calling them uh the opposite sex
named using pronouns and hiding it from
the parents you people are weirdos
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you really
[Music]
thank you